I remember the arugula phase.
Every time I walked towards your
desk you smelled like a salad.
Hello everyone, my name is Lana Hum.
My name is Mack Cole-Edelsack.
We are two members of the Exhibition Design
team at the Museum of Modern Art.
As exhibition designers, we work with the
curators and a large team at the museum to
craft the environments
that house the exhibitions.
We wanted to give you a
behind-the-scenes look and a chance
to ask some questions about what
goes into making these exhibitions.
Questions like what are the considerations
exhibition designers have to take into account?
Things like wall placement, colors,
lighting, conservation requirements.
Working with artists and also
making sure that all of it
maintains true to the curators' vision
and the meaning behind
what they are hanging.
Or how does one become an exhibition designer.
We'll answer those and a whole lot more, so
please leave your questions in the comment
section below and be sure
to tune in live when we'll
be answering those and more questions
that you post during the livestream.
Until then check out some of these other videos
and be sure to subscribe to the museum's YouTube
channel so you'll get an
alert when we go live.
See you then.
I know.
We can talk about
arugula like endlessly.
No problem.
Exactly.